thank you for coming tonight welcome to
the Simons Foundation presents panel
discussion featuring writers and editors
from quanta magazine
I'm Thomas Linn I'm the editor of the
magazine and tonight we have a lot of
interesting things to talk about we will
be discussing some of the new ideas and
emerging themes in physics biology and
mathematics some of the same topics
covered in the magazine and that are
also presented in our two new books
Alice and Bob meet the wall of fire and
the prime number conspiracy one quick
note about the video you just saw we
will be saving audience questions for
the end and will be bringing microphones
to the aisles so you don't need to use
the speakers in front of you on the
chairs I want to thank the Museum of
mathematics for being here tonight to
help make the books available to all of
you at this event and also to MIT press
for working with us to publish the books
tonight as those of you who read quanta
are probably familiar with we will be
talking about some fairly profound ideas
and somewhat highly technical somewhat
technical ideas but we will again like
the magazine try to make it as
accessible and as dragon free as
possible it is a great pleasure to
introduce our four panelists tonight to
my left is Natalie Walsh over she is the
senior physics writer and editor at
quanta she has been winning lots of
awards are all well deserved in 2016 she
won both the excellence in statistical
reporting award and the Everett Clark
Seth Payne award for young science
journalists and just last year she won
the prestigious American Institute of
Physics science communication award next
to her as John Rennie our deputy editor
who leads our biology coverage he is the
former editor-in-chief of Scientific
American he was also the host of a TV
series on the Weather Channel called
hacking the planet
next to him is Kevin Hartnett our senior
math writer and he has had several
articles republished in the annual best
writing on mathematics anthology last
but not least we have Robert dijkgraaf
is a mathematical physicist and a quanta
columnist is the director of the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton New Jersey and he's also a
painter and extraordinary science
communicator so I'm glad to have all of
you here thank you for coming and thank
you all for being here tonight both the
live audience and those watching on the
live feed online now we don't have a lot
of time here we don't have an hour and
we have a whole universe of ideas to
talk about and so we're gonna just jump
right in and start with the first
question which comes from the our
science collection Alice and Bob made
the wall of fire the first question in
the book asks why doesn't our universe
make sense many of you are probably
aware and in 2012 there was a major
discovery in physics the Higgs boson was
detected at Large Hadron Collider in
Switzerland but physicists were hoping
to also detect some other particles as
well that would help them make sense of
our universe those particles have not
been detected which leads to questions
of whether our universe is natural we'll
ask Natalie about in a second and also
to this fear that physicists have had
for a number of years that if they don't
detect these particles that they will
essentially face what they call a
nightmare scenario so with that I want
Natalie if you could start off by just
setting this up for us what do this mean
by the universe being natural or
unnatural and you know what is it that
is behind this nightmare scenario yeah
so I think a lot of people when they
hear the idea that the universe is
unnatural that just inherently seems
like an oxymoron and so over the past
five years I've kind of hopefully gotten
bad
are trying to explain what this means
and so what it mean what naturalness
means in a scientific sense is basically
that the variables in the equation can
take different values and the values
themselves of different constants and
things in the equations should all kind
of work together in a way that that
makes sense and there's a more precise
way of thinking about it but with the
Higgs boson mass the problem is that
this particle the Higgs Higgs boson has
a mass which is many many many orders of
magnitude different from what Cena's
like the fundamental mass in nature and
so this enormous hierarchy between the
two values basically seems to two
physicists like something that needs to
be explained and they had this brilliant
explanation which was supersymmetry that
has been sort of the paradigm for a long
time even before supersymmetry similar
supersymmetry was even searched for
people just kind of believed that it was
true and that you would just find the
particles because it was such a
beautiful way to make the constants all
kind of work out together but instead
they did not find these supersymmetric
particles at the Large Hadron Collider
and that's really created a fascinating
time in physics where this kind of
paradigm and in principle of naturalness
that was leading to people to build a
Large Hadron Collider to look for these
particles that that all basically failed
and now physicists don't know how to
make the equations natural and they also
don't even know if this naturalness idea
is even was a principle they should have
been holding another way think about it
I think is that much of what we have now
in terms of some of our bedrock theories
and physics came from the idea that the
universe would be natural right and yet
now if in fact
these variables are constantly we're
talking about are in essence fine-tuned
then it almost leads you to believe that
our universe is unnatural and maybe just
one of many universes out there and so
talk a little bit about what that means
if there's actually a multiverse and and
do this really like that idea yeah well
so yeah so exactly if if the equation
constants in the equations kind of all
make perfect sense with each other then
you can imagine that our universe is
this kind of inevitable structure where
everything is kind of cohesive and
there's some underlying kind of theory
that that predicts everything based on
you know pies and - and you know maybe a
factor of four somewhere but very simple
kind of math that underlies everything
but if you have these really weirdly you
know and when I say the constants are
are weird I mean like one is something
like a billion billion billion billion
times bigger than another constant in in
the equations and so there's this huge
hierarchy the only like a way to get
that is if everything is just kind of
random in our universe and the constants
there was some sort of miraculous almost
really really unlikely fine-tuning where
you know the Higgs mass was really tiny
even though the fundamental mass is
really huge and that that difference
allowed our universe to give rise to
life and so that's why sirs would have a
different yeah yeah and in order to have
that kind of very unlikely event then
you have to have a huge variety of other
universes in order for ours to be
realized
so that's where the multiverse idea kind
of comes in but it's people hate that
idea because it's untestable like it's
the idea now yeah I mean it's yeah I
mean it's kind of like people who have
already a climatic to the idea of the
multiverse so like this makes perfect
sense there's there's
many many universes why should our
universe be the only one why should why
should there just be one universe that
happens to be half life and not a people
who are against the multiverse think
that it's untestable and that this is
kind of a cop-out
saying well we can't explain this big
hierarchy so let's just say that it's
all random and there's no explanation so
I want to also ask Robert about this
since he's the director of the event
it's super advanced study some of the
researchers at the Institute are
studying this exact problem and and I
wonder if you know I want to get your
perspective on whether there's a sense
or that the universe is in fact natural
we just need to find the right theory or
if things are trending towards sort of
acceptance that it's unnatural and and
sort of buying into in thinking about
how the multiverse idea might might help
us first of all all my opinions are here
just my own sorry I'm not speaking it's
actually something very much in debate
and I think actually this is kind of
wonderful expression where Fineman
explains how particle physics develops
in his lifetime he says knowing if this
great beautiful thing fits and then
there are little experiments and they do
not quite fit them you try to hold
things together some part you have to
give up
it looks very ugly and then after a very
confusing period it starts to hang again
to get again and it's beautiful but it's
beautiful in a more subtle more deeper
sense so we know we go through these
transitions so I feel particle physics
is very much at that point because there
was an obvious scenario with the Higgs
particle where in deeds know certain
other particles would be found and
everything would fit together they do
not but you know it's it's it's not
clear that we have to switch to the
other frame we say well it's all chaos
it's all random etc so I think we are
really in this kind of mixed state but I
think an important question we should
realize even about the Stanmore rule as
it is there are lots of numbers that
appear there and just you know even in
the masses of the particles that we all
know there are huge differences no day
they differ as much as a whale compared
to a fly
and and none of us have any idea where
these are real constants or nature or
are they determined by some other set of
equations are they the solutions of
equations or are they constants of
nature that somehow Nature picked out
for once overall we simply don't know
and but if you are if you theoretical
physicist and you write down any
equation that should describe the
universe and it could be a kind of
cartoon version of the equations we have
it very easy happens that you create
more than one universe right because in
some sense it's if you think about it we
almost are saying that you know if there
is a unique universe we are searching
not only of law searching for laws of
nature to describe physics or science in
the terms of you have an input then
something happens and we calculate the
output but we even are trying to
determine there's only one solution and
that solution is us so that's that's
rare I don't know if any equation in
science that has only one solution you
know or it's so whatever the if it's
literally you know you could have a
little potential something so think of
it as a mountain landscape but very
simple but only one Valley it's very
easy this little bump and it's a second
Valley and then what happens to that
solution so that's something that you
know I think cosmology confronts physic
with and the thing you know it's it's a
different set of questions because we
are not describing what often said you
know science is about answering the
question what's next but it's really you
know why this whole thing and I think
that's actually where we're struggling
with it I think it's very exciting to
see that although all of us hate I think
the multiverse in the sense you know
it's free for all we do know that we had
a whole sequence over many centuries
where our sphere of what we think of as
the world the universe has been growing
from our planets to our solar system to
our galaxy at subsidiary's
increasing and we feel entirely
comfortable talking about perhaps
galaxies
that we will never see now that are
outside the Hubble radius that's simply
you know because of the expanding
universe will not able to ever witness
it's almost as though think oh we feel
comfortable with that I think you know
there are things I don't feel quite
comfortable something happening you know
few blocks away I can't observe it but
probably it's out there in thinking only
of our own University we might be
provincial we might trying to do
something I'm sorry I think we should
always be aware of this this feeling the
final Express that you know you feel Wow
moment it's it's going in the wrong
direction but what you're doing is
something I would also like tunneling
through a barrier and you might end up
in a new Valley that's much greener than
the one that we are in right now yeah so
this leads very well to the next
question I have which you know when you
think about the multiverse idea you
think about things like string theory
these are all ideas that are you know
powerful tools and ways for thinking
about our universe but there's really no
empirical evidence for these theories
and so I want to talk a little bit about
what we mean by evidence in science and
Natalie in 2015 you covered a debate in
Munich just about this question of you
know given that it's getting harder and
harder and may not even be possible to
find empirical evidence for some of the
these most sort of exciting theories
that are happening at the forefront of
physics right now what exactly does it
mean - for what counts as evidence in
that case is you know something that's
mathematical enough do we want to follow
sort of the
Karl Popper idea that something has to
be falsifiable in this way which a lot
of these ideas that we've been talking
about today are not talk to us a little
bit about what were some of the the key
arguments that you covered during that
debate yeah it was a really amazing
opportunity to go to this conference in
Munich and kind of have this really big
theme of physics right now come to
climactic point where you had people
from both sides coming together and
basically arguing about whether string
theory and the multiverse and these
ideas that are not directly testable or
scientific or whether science is kind of
going off course by focusing on these
kinds of theories and one big I think
one big theme that emerged is there
there's so much anger and passion on
both sides and and that is usually a
mark of confusion and a confusing time
where things are subject to change
rapidly and I think what was kind of
what one thing that was clear is that
it's not really about physicists kind of
going down the wrong path and becoming
more interested in speculative theories
when they should be more grounded it's
really that we as a humanity we've kind
of gotten to the end of the points where
we can really push further like we we
can no longer build instruments that can
probe to a much smaller scale than we
have we can see out to the cosmic
horizon but we'll never see further than
that so we're kind of coming to the end
of where we can actually test our ideas
but theorists have of course because of
just logical kind of thinking about how
things would extend have gone much
further in both directions so they're
thinking about the multiverse and large
scales and they're thinking about
strings and string theory on the small
scales even though we'll never see that
that far down and so a big part of the
debate is whether there are other kinds
of evidence besides direct empirical
evidence some people think it's just
blasphemy to even suggest that there
might be ways of kind of gaining
confidence in a theory that is not
having to do with experiments and
testing the theory but other people
think that just by looking at the logic
of an idea you can gain confidence in it
and so the big question is with string
theory
our physicists just kind of fooling
themselves or dazzled by the beauty of
it or are they seeing real kind of
qualities in string theory that seem
compelling enough to actually believe it
we're gonna come back to this question
in a bit thanks for setting up that that
debate for us you know thinking about
evidence in the realm of physics there
are clear examples of very testable
ideas and experiments and and empirical
evidence for what we know in physics but
but there are as now he was saying many
newer theorists that rely more on
mathematics to sort of prove that at
least it's it's something else largely
consistent Kevin in the world of pure
mathematics which does not rely on the
physical world and and deals with you
know abstractions where evidence is not
inherently empirical what is evidence in
mathematics what counts as evidence sure
agent I mean what counts as knowledge is
a proof and short of that you know kind
of what matters we ran it an article in
quanta a couple weeks ago on this
concept of the rank of elliptic curves
and whether or not the rank is bounded
is there a cap on how big it can be and
there have been this kind of this this
the see changes over the last century
hundred years ago people thought for
sure it had to be a cap and in the 60s
and 70s they thought no way it must be
unbounded and now they're kind of
opinion is shifted back toward there
being a cap but kind of why right no one
has proven it one way or the other or
even really come that close and so I
think they're kind of there there are
different types of evidence that matter
and that move opinion there's
computational evidence and as computers
get better you can do more computations
and if every time you find a solution to
the Riemann zeta-function it lies on the
critical strip that makes you think
every solution lies on this on every
zero of the function lies on this trip
so there's computational evidence there
are heuristics if you kind of compare
something if you're interested in
understanding a property of object a and
you can't prove that property
you know but you know that object a is
kind of like object B and object B has
this analogous property and we can prove
that the property holds for B that's a
guy heuristic that lets us think that
the property also holds for a and you
see that happening
sometimes in mathematics and physics
often provides the kind of a source of
evidence for mathematical things being
true I know in the collection Robert has
a column that talks about mirror
symmetry and mirror symmetry is
something we've covered in quanta as
well so physicists kind of proposed that
there are these two models of string
theory that seemed equivalent and when
you think about those models in
mathematics it tells you that these two
types of geometric spaces are equivalent
these symplectic spaces in these complex
spaces so physics kind of proposes that
they're physical theories work if these
two types of spaces are equivalent and
then mathematically you might then go
out and actually try to prove that these
two spaces that's kind of a source of of
evidence in math and I guess I would say
what is the upshot here because you know
evidence is not a proof and evidence can
in some ways not often doesn't lead you
at all closer to a proof than you were
before but I think the main thing it
does is it kind of emboldened mathematic
mathematicians to to pursue lines of
inquiry I ought to a mathematician once
who told me that he'd been working on
this problem for a long time and then he
heard that some other mathematician
approved you know prove the conjecture
was true and he didn't know what they
did to prove it was true but is knowing
that it had been proven true like you
know the next day he figured out his own
proof because he just said yeah it
probably worked so I think that is kind
of a major that that's something that
evidence can do in mathematics that's
great thank you Kevin
you know we live in a time right now
where I think evidence at least arguably
evidence and and facts are almost
existential issues for our democratic
nation and but you know I want us to ask
Robert as a mathematical physicist
because you work sort of in both worlds
to put non empirical evidence into
context for us when is it useful how
does it help us move Science and
Mathematics forward
when we cannot rely on evidence from the
physical world well by the way your your
your anecdotes suggest that you should
have fake news outs that the famous
conjecture was proven because then
somebody might feel oh I can do this too
like if we didn't if we don't have
empirical evidence for for say a physics
theory
can we just then say I like this story
better even in pure math there is kind
of almost the art form of the conjecture
right so what makes a good conjecture
it's by definition something that hasn't
been proven you have some suggested
evidence perhaps some cases etc so I
think both the math and physics kind of
the dotted line where we want to go is
as important as actually you know taking
the steps improving the points in fact I
think you know it's this more visionary
elements both in math and physics that
are motivating us why are you working on
a certain problem because it's not just
one step further but it's a step along a
route that will take you to a completely
different world so in some sense you
have to make sense of a few facts if
you're number theorists you know perhaps
we can work in concrete cases if you a
theoretical physicist
now Nature has given us a few hints that
the world is not yet finished so if you
think of the standard model there are
things like neutrino masses there's the
Higgs particle that doesn't really quite
work you know there is the difference
between particles and antiparticles so
you somehow know this is this has to
Nature has found a solution to it so and
I think it's that kind of soft thinking
perhaps you can say because it's not
being which is incredibly important
because it's actually guide are our
thoughts and you know there's a long
tradition of you know theoretical
physicists getting things wrong but
there's also a long tradition of somehow
being that their theories are smarter
than the person who proposed it that
they're holding back now Einstein is
famous for many of the consequence
general relativity he felt uncomfortable
with you know Dirac basically on paper
predicting antiparticles but no nobody
had seen these particles so you held
back so I think it's it's very important
that we also know encourage guided
imagination guided with previous
examples guided with previous
experiments etc push theorists because
you can also make the mistake so
somebody said in one of discussions who
needs to thought please and I think
indeed in thinking we don't need
policing we just need smart thinking and
it should be based on sometimes what we
call intuition but I think intuition is
our way which by experience we learn to
deal with kind of lack of data error
bars in our thinking and trying to find
whether there is something that you know
can you kind of fit on some sense a
curve through this and that's so part of
theory should also be that you're out in
front of the data and and guide and it's
actually quite literally what we need
because same modern experiments people
don't realize that when they create
billions of collisions a second but the
machine can only keep so to say a few so
you even the experimental the one thing
they want to know is what should we look
for because they can't look for
everything at the same time so anyway
you're speaking to this dynamic between
theory and experiments sometimes the
experiments they give rise to new
theories so as you need theory is to
then know what to look for it with your
experiment is both so in that sense I
think if you have a diverse community
but people are searching in many
different directions that's good if we
all like on one little cluster thinking
the same way and we all say yes to this
or no to that I think that would be very
dangerous thank you now I want to turn
to the idea of biological evidence
because you know in physics at least in
theoretical particle physics we're sort
of it seems like we're kind of hitting a
wall in some ways but with biology it's
you know a dodgy biologists I think in
general insist on empirical evidence
right and and yet biology is a very
complex subject also the systems are
extremely complex
so it's not necessarily easy to make
sense of the data that you have and it
makes sense of the evidence that you're
collecting and also if you're thinking
about things like evolution and studying
how evolution works obviously obviously
to everyone but I think to to people who
care about evidence obviously there's an
overwhelming amount of evidence for
evolution itself there's no question
that evolution itself occurred but there
are questions about specific mechanisms
and by which it works and and thinking
back you know obvious we can't go back
in time to see exactly what happened so
there's all sorts of challenges to
understanding biological evidence I'm
John I'd I'd love for you to talk a
little bit about what new kinds of data
evidence we're gaining in biology to
help us better understand things like
evolution and what life is sure so
obviously all kinds of information
available to us can find a way of
working the way into different sorts of
biology and biology is a many different
things in many different situations just
as life itself is I feel like biology in
some ways is faced with a similar sort
of problem so the one you were talking
about with physics in in that we in in
in biology world there's also a certain
sort of level of tension because our
understanding of life as being result of
evolution is that there's obviously a
huge element of randomness that is the
the germ of the the source of all the
variation on which life begins but then
other things that are playing much more
regularity to then lead us to certain
sorts of ends so contingency is
obviously very important in our
understanding of biology in the history
of life on earth and anyplace else but
what can be intellectually unsatisfying
about that is that you don't want us to
just think that life is just a result of
some random thing that just happened we
would like to think that we understand
certain sorts of principles that made
certain kinds of things more likely than
others so there's a certain kind of
balance that we're trying to go to with
that and I think where that's surfaced a
lot in in a couple of the two ways that
I think strike me is really particularly
fascinating these days and would drive a
lot of the biology one is that our
traditional view of life is one that's
based on sort of being something kind of
like what we are you know we would talk
about there is no universally
agreed-upon
a definition for life we talk about it
as some being sort of like a
thermodynamically open system we talk
about as being being made of cells we
talk about it having like a property of
homeostasis and that the these life
reproduces and so forth but what's
interesting is that is that when we says
we've been learning more about life and
the diversity of life what we're seeing
is that a lot of the things that we
thought of as sort of the mainstream the
stuff like us but we are weirdly more of
an edge case than we thought and that a
lot of the things that we thought were
the edge cases are much more mainstream
so viruses everybody whoever has that
sort of sense of Oh life is made of you
know life is independent and it
perpetuates itself and it's made of
cells you would look at viruses and you
would think well they're weird sort of
parasitic thing are they alive let's
let's try to move past that well what
we're discovering is that viruses are in
fact a gigantic Lee central part of all
of life that there are more viruses and
more types of viruses and an abundance
of abundance of viruses in nature that's
hugely more important than we ever
thought and in fact that there are
viruses that are bigger than some types
of bacteria so all the different sorts
of things that we were using to sort of
marginalize some types of biological
phenomena because they weren't like us
turn out to be much more important than
we thought so one thing is that in that
seek that search for the right sort of
evidence we have to pay more attention
to those things that we didn't think
we're important the other thing is that
we've traditionally thought of certainly
post Darwin that we have we have tended
to think that that that we we needed to
really look to evolution as being the
source of all of the order that we would
find in life but what we're increasingly
finding and what is a fascinating area
of research that I'm lucky that we
actually get to write about so much at
quanta is the way in which life can be
treated as a mathematical system or a
physical system and that a lot of the
sources of order that we see in the
living world are already basically there
to be taken advantage of within physical
systems anyway and that life didn't have
to evolve certain sorts of systems so
the fact that cells a sort of default
shape of a cell is being round it's not
round because it was evolved to be round
it's round because a
fear is the natural minimal shape of
being a weight which contains something
inside a membrane and we're finding more
and more that some kinds of physical
phenomena with increasing levels of
sophistication can be sources of vitally
important structure and functions in
biology that's a huge frontier for us
it's certainly a been a recent rise in
the power of biophysics and trying to
merge things from these you know kind of
from you know the small from the physics
in terms you know at a more basic
particle level to the sort of larger
more emergent state that that biology
tends to to examine you know thinking
about evolution and and life and even
our own experiences everything that we
experience and think about in terms of
of these things involves a
directionality to time right that's how
we experience things I'm looking up at
the clock you know every now and then to
see you know where we are in terms of
time here but in physics the cost of
time isn't really well-defined the
fundamental laws of physics things can
kind of move forward or backward in time
what are physicists doing about that
and you know is as I understand it based
on your reporting and their story in our
science collection is it connected in
some way to quantum entanglement is that
helping us understand what time is from
a physics perspective yes sort of so I
think there's many different mysteries
about time that are all kind of related
or maybe they're the same mystery so
there's there's like time as kind of
this background it's dimension that
we're moving in and then there's the
arrow of time so the fact that there's a
directionality of time but that arrow
might kind of be on top of the
background of existing time and then we
also have like this perception of time
that changes but then that also our
perception might also be more related to
actual time than we think so I feel like
there's when people talk about time it's
even hard to understand what the
question is sometimes but but for sure
it's one
the big mysteries of physics and I think
it's sort of I mean I would say it's
maybe the big mystery of physics I don't
know how you feel about that but I just
I think it's sort of very very tied with
all the other things that are most
mysterious so like quantum gravity and
the nature of the Big Bang and all of
these things like I think if we knew if
we understood time we would also
understand these all these other things
but there is but yeah there there there
is progress in understanding the arrow
of time so why time can move forward but
you can't kind of you know even though
we can move in three dimensions of space
we can't move backwards in time and I
think that is becoming more and more
understood as being associated with them
with quality the growth of quantum
entanglement so the growth of things
kind of all particles all interacting in
the universe and getting more and more
basically where their own state can't be
defined individually their state is very
dependent on the states of other things
and so information is kind of shared
between many many different particles so
this gradual growth of entanglement of
particles and stuff in the universe is
more and more being associated with the
flow of time because it's very hard to
unentangled things don't become
unentangled over time so but even that I
think is a lot of people would view that
as a separate question from just why is
there this sense why is everything not
happening at one instant right now like
how do you get this how is everything
unpacked so that you're allowed to have
like particles becoming entangled more
and more entangled I think that's
completely unanswered sure yeah
so I do want to get Roberts take on this
as well I mean it's it's quite right
it's one of the great paradoxes so I
think one hand be quite confident that
space and time
are one and the same thing so Einstein
told us and everything all the evidence
points out that your view understand
space and time you can basically have
any combination of it and then on top of
that I think we have much more
understanding about the kind of the Ovid
say like the granular nature of space we
know that if you want to study space at
the smallest distances we would have to
concentrate energy so tightly that
little black hole would form and it
would basically eat a little hole in the
space so you could never see it at the
smallest distances and there are great
theoretical models how space can in the
appear emerge out of quantum
fluctuations quantum information etc so
it's like not fundamental something that
comes out so if you take these two
arguments you said time should also
emerge it should also be sure to have a
kind of a granular in nature of time it
would be terrific because people always
ask you what happened at the Big Bang or
before the Big Bang but if time is
something like a river that you go
upstream at some point you will just
have little drops of water the whole
concept of a river would disappear and
you don't have a paradox the rivers have
beginnings that's perfectly fine but I
think obviously nobody has only how to
make this work and what we find in
particular I think that quantum
mechanics which often is seen now in
this battle between general relativity
gravity and quantum mechanics that like
quantum mechanics has the last word
because all the theories still that we
have like string theory etc they use
kind of ordinary quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics makes a huge
distinction between time and the other
directions because again the describes
how things evolves in time whether it's
a wave function or a tangle and etc but
this can't be the last word so we kind
of have to give up and so I think
there's a lot of physics you think in
this battle between gravity and quantum
where somehow quantum seem to have won
the first round in our ideas but in the
second round we'll have to give up
because the concept of time is totally
conventional in quantum mechanics and
that's not saying that has to somehow
disappear
so who knows
that's actually extremely exciting I
said and it's actually so fascinating
but of course because you've all you
know physicists are pushing you know and
they're calm build a microscope that's
small enough or telescope it's big
enough to explore actually time is
happening right now it's something
that's happening here we're experiencing
it so physics to a large extent is also
about the things that just surround us
and you can ask very deep questions we
can be totally confused about everyday
concepts which is actually humbling
because people have been thinking about
times for millennia but it shows that we
not necessarily have to build huge
experiments we can just think about it
and and and wonder about it and the
biggest puzzles of physics perhaps time
is it it's actually something that we
are experiencing right now this moment
whatever that sentence means I mean I I
love to read the articles about about
time in the rest purely was it kind of
like you know tourists going through
this area of things because I'm
fascinated just to see what comes up in
it but what also really strikes me about
that all the time if sorry it's
inevitable our understanding our
appreciation of time this way comes in
the fact that we evolved to have some
kind of experience of time it was
something for whatever reasons out of
necessity or again contingency or
whatever we evolved to have an
appreciation of time that works the way
that it does and it's deeply ingrained
inside the nature of life itself I mean
if you if if all things down here the
cells down there the most primitive
level they all make they all make use of
time they all keep track of time to
organize their activities in different
ways and I mean it's really fascinating
to understand why that is the case and
whether there is an option for it to be
any different way about like whether is
is there something about that we
appreciate time because this is the only
way that we would have to perceive it in
that way or you know could something be
like the the aliens in I think
Vonnegut's book slaughterhouse-five
where it's like the aliens that
tralfamadorians there is though who
appreciated they they experienced all
times simultaneously could something do
that or is
or is there something built into the
nature of of the physics that then in
biology has to come out of that makes
that impossible they did question right
it's time fundamental is it a merchant
is it just a figment of our imagination
is it an illusion this is something that
physicists and biologists at a different
level are very keen to understand and
and philosophers too so getting back to
the question of math and evidence you
know one of us to think a little bit
about the question of math as the
universal language of science because
certainly a lot of the science that we
cover at quanta tends to involve some
very rigorous math and you know there's
a pretty well-known essay from 1960 by
the Nobel Prize winning physicist Eugene
Wigner in which he talked about the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics so we all are familiar with
math that can come out of physical
things we can think of a circle we think
about you know PI and the relationship
between the circumference and diameter
there's a look at motions of orbits of
planets things like that but there's
been a lot of mathematics developed
separate from what we can observe and
and somehow that mathematics some of it
at least has found its way back into
physics and back into descriptions of
the real world and so that's I think
what he was referring to and it also
sort of speaks to the sort of the deep
question of whether mathematics is you
know invented or discovered and some of
the mathematicians I've spoken to tend
to say it's both right that both things
are happening but I wanted to ask Robert
about this
well actually I'm sorry I'm gonna start
with Kevin first because Kevin wrote
about a strange link between physics and
math in one of your stories in in the
science book and we talked a little bit
about particle physics and pure
mathematics yeah this was a story about
a mathematician at Oxford named Francis
Brown who was just kind of exploring
this correspondence between these
important numbers in math and these
important numbers in particle physics
so when particle physicists run you
collide some two particles together and
they want to kind of follow that chain
reaction forward and try and determine
what happens they use this thing called
the Fineman diagram and each Fineman
diagram you associate by say a
probability that the the collision
played out kind of the way your diagram
said it played out and so you of this
number describing these collisions call
called the amplitude and then there all
these other numbers in pure math that
are called motives are periods of
motives but the point being there just
like a characteristic number of
algebraic equations and these P's these
numbers these probabilities for these
these Fineman diagrams seem to kind of
match these these periods of motives in
this field of algebraic geometry and so
Francis Brown in coordination with
physicists really it's a quite dynamic
back and forth they're having has been
trying to explore like well why would
these what is what is the structure of
these numbers that we're seeing coming
out of these physics experiments because
it does seem like they have a structure
they have this thing called a group
structure that mathematicians would be
interested in understanding and at the
same time if there is this structure
what does that mean physically because
if these these periods have or these
amplitudes have this group structure
it's suggesting something symmetrical is
happening in in the way these particle
collisions are having and that symmetry
should have an actual physical meaning
so it's kind of a this dynamic back and
forth between the two and I think it's
one instance I would just say I've just
I think one of the most exciting things
going on in in math today is this I feel
like a growing collaboration between
number theory and physics geometry and
topology and physics have been kind of
intertwined for several decades but
number theory and physics are really
starting to communicate a lot more in
this article in the in the book strange
numbers found in particle collisions is
one instance of that and that connection
is it was a complete surprise right I
think in the story you said something
like it's it's like you know counting
grains of rice and seeing prime numbers
or something like that that's no reason
to believe you know they should be there
so now I want to turn to Robert because
you have a different you have a column
in in the book where you refer to
something that
sounds like what Eugene Wigner was
saying but it's a little bit different
you said there appears to be an
unreasonable effectiveness of quantum
theory in mathematics that somehow
quantum theory is leading to new
mathematics well you encourage
interaction between I would see
mathematics and the sciences and but
it's indeed a little bit of a kind of an
arms race of these two fields so for
instance no we would say well math is
wonderful to describe the motions of
planets etc but Newton had to invent
calculus to do this right the math
wasn't there yet and it was now we see
there's a standard part of mathematics
but very much inspired by by mechanics
and so I would say you know it's math is
very forceful tool for scientists but
also nature is a great mathematics
teacher oh and teaches us mathematics in
a very deep way and I think these
lessons have only started now we know
that you know nature is quantum
mechanical so that's one thing we know
and it's nothing an approximation really
it's if you what's the fundamental way
to think about nature's quantum
mechanical and yet I think most of our
geometrical concepts and or just our all
our mathematical concepts are kind of
classical nature we thinking in points
and lines and curves and velocity and so
all of these would make perfectly sense
in classical mechanics so our mass I
think is still almost like 19th century
a little bit and we haven't fully
embraced quantum mechanics now turns out
that certain ideas in quantum physics
which are very unnatural to us human
beings because we are not elementary
particles so we never had two places at
the same time we're never in it we never
entangled with somebody else
it's although we use these words but we
are not so technically really not right
and so we have very little intuition you
might say our brains have been shaped by
basically classical mathematics so
another question is can the quantum
world be a good math teacher and it
turns out that you know there's certain
things in quantum mechanics which elect
perfect form ethics from mathematics
from modern mathematics and modern
Maddox doesn't want to look at one
object the modern style of mathematics
issue look at everything you know every
member of the family and you not look at
one object but at their in the mutual
relations relations among relations etc
ability is very kind of communal view
and actually is exactly what quantum
mechanics does it's it it's you know
it's the famous sum over histories if
you go home today you know if you feel
you take one path but quantum
mechanically you take all possible paths
each with a certain probability very
unlikely only allowed many particles
have to deal with it but actually it
turns out that also it's wonderful
method more mathematicians to deal with
that to kind of try to think like a
quantum particle and it and and again
here the proof or the the evidence for
the usefulness of this this unreasonable
effectiveness of these ideas is that it
actually leads to concrete proof of
mathematical theorem so there is a whole
series of results proving in the last
few decades which I would say been
proven or understood using quantum logic
and the remarkable thing I feel is that
we are able to push our intuition even
our mathematical intuition in an area
that the world of small particles well
none of us have any concrete experience
I'm taking mental notes here by the way
for future quanta story I mean that's
such a great thing you know think
friends of the life science John but you
were saying no what would happen
literally happens if we move mass into
that area which is as ill understood so
to say and we have as little intuition
as we have elementary particles and so
science can really inform new math in
very deep ways I would say the we did a
profile in the last year of math
initially min Yun Kim who is very much
using some quantum ideas to try and
understand the rational solutions to
equations it's hard to find the rational
solutions to equations but Kim has this
idea that if you think about these
spaces of spaces that Robert was kind of
just talking about you can kind of the
the rational solution sees equation so
when do you want to find are like the
classical path travel
and the kind of the all the other
solutions are those the the past not
taken in the classical world and an
interesting thing about that article
though was Kim has kind of harbored this
idea that these ideas from physics
should inform these ideas from math for
more than a decade and he like didn't
want to tell anyone cuz he was really
afraid number theorists would you know
would think it was just quackery yes so
he kind of worked up the courage over
the course of a decade and now I was
trying to you know get gained some in
hearings but it takes a while I think to
kind of break out of these ways of
thinking about these math mathematical
questions and kind of admit a new
perspective and none of us would ever
think of this ourselves it's no you can
meditate for a millennium but you will
never find the rules of quantum
mechanics sort of experiment nature of
forces to think like these crazy ways
yeah so I'm gonna ask another question
but while we're talking our volunteers
here will be bringing microphones up to
the aisles here in case anybody had
anybody from the audience has any
questions so please start making your
way to the aisle if you have a question
and we're gonna line up behind two
microphones that they're setting up
right now as we speak and we'll just
continue on but in a few minutes we're
gonna start taking questions so so far
tonight
we've talked about the nightmare
scenario in fundamental particle physics
we've talked about the difficulty that
we have with evidence in science and and
what that means we've talked it with
about how we don't know what time is
it's been kind of a little bit negative
and I apologize for that that's my fault
for leading the conversation this way
but yeah I want to end sort of on a
positive note and thinking and asking
every one of our panelists to talk about
what is the most exciting thing that
you're seeing in the area that you cover
and write about or research and you know
what is it likely to lead to and how is
it going to bear fruit in the future so
in physics for example what are you
seeing out there that's most promising
well so there is so much happening in
physics and
I didn't definitely didn't mean to
convey that there isn't I think we've
been talking about fundamental physics
so cosmology and particle physics but of
course there's so much happening in
condensed matter physics so better
understanding materials and it's
actually fascinating stuff happening
there and also just like turbulence so
there are all kinds of different areas
that aren't kind of getting at like the
heart of what's going on with the
universe also believe but even at even
at the larger sort of you know sort of
larger scale like oh for example has
been hugely transformative in terms of
our ability to see what's out there
right and so we're now detecting
gravitational waves from colliding black
holes and that's helping us kind of math
out and understand the universe and
especially the role of black holes in
the universe but I would say actually
what excites me most is that in this
period of kind of turmoil and crisis
basically in fundamental physics there
is there are a lot of new ideas kind of
bubbling off and mostly what it is is
people are questioning the assumptions
that they've held for a long time or
they just kind of felt like we would be
playing out this plan that we'd laid out
of you know looking for supersymmetry
and finding it and then understanding
kind of how all the particles in nature
fit together and then kind of you know
and maybe getting evidence for string
theory somehow and then we're done and
that obviously has not happened so
people are going back and really
questioning the assumptions like
naturalness they're trying to better
understand the patterns in the equation
so all kind of mysterious things about
the equations that we have already to
try to understand why there they are the
way they are and I think there is just a
lot of fascinating stuff coming out
absolutely yeah we talked about you know
there's this sort of you know moniker of
the nightmare scenario out there but
really talking to especially some of the
younger physicists out there they
actually see a big wide-open space to
see have a lot of opportunity
they no longer have to follow their
mentors into any field they can just
create their own programs now they can
think about you know anything that they
can imagine to to try to create new
physics what about in in your realm and
in biology so I'm gonna slightly cheat
because I sort of alluded to one of
these before which is I think that you
really in terms of a big concept the
idea that embedded within nature just
just your nature of the physical world
is such that it can drive a lot of the
form and what we find in nature so there
there are scientists like Jeremy England
at MIT for example who've been
developing arguments that suggest that
there's a kind of inevitability to life
because life is a natural manifestation
of a tendency in the material world to
keep finding better and better ways to
dissipate entropy so just so I think
that that is kind of a fascinating idea
that way that basically that life that
there's an inevitability to life that
way and just that the complexity that we
see arising in life over time that there
might actually be an innate
directionality toward more complexity
that comes to that but even beyond that
I mean just the thing that I think is
just endlessly fascinating is all the
stuff that we you would think we would
understand about life by now how often
we really don't you know craig Venter in
his group a few years ago they said
let's take all that we understand about
genomics and let's try to create them
the simplest living cell we possibly
could and so they took all the kind of
things and they tried to figure out what
would be the minimum number of cell of
genes they could put into an artificial
cell and they tried and tried and tried
and it was a dismal failure because they
couldn't keep those things alive so they
tried a different way where they started
off with a really small cell and then
just started randomly knocking things
out to see what would be left and what
they were left with the end was this
artificial organism that had only like
473 genes I think but what which you
know really really small it's I got
tenth the size of what you'd find in
something like an e coli but here's the
kicker of those 473 like 150 of them we
have no idea what those genes do so even
when we tried to get it down to the
minimum number of stuff we found out we
still don't even understand why those
things were alive and so I there's so
much still to just learn at that basic
level of what our
genome is doing a lot to learn yes come
yeah I think there's I mean a lot
exciting work going on in math I
mentioned the search for rational
solutions to polynomial equations
there's there like several kind of
exciting initiatives in that respect
one mathematician recently I know I
think that Matheny's are optimistic that
we will be kind of identifying rational
solutions in a more systematic way I
think kind of a work that kind of puts
analysis and algebra in conversation
with each other and allows
mathematicians kind of port results back
and forth there's like a lot of exciting
work there and and that opens up kind of
solutions on both sides yeah those are
definitely true certainly a lot that's
going on in mathematics and things are
maybe it's harder to talk about them all
as one thing but but that's those are
great examples and I would highlight the
kind of the collision of the dismal and
a very large so where cosmology and
quantum theory we are colliding you know
we I think we all are excited about what
we do not understand so it's I think
most of you know 95 percent of the
universe is ill Institutes it's dark
matter dark energy we know there are
black holes we notice something like the
Big Bang we know that nature found a way
to resolve the logical problems so these
are I think often said these are the
paradoxes of the 21st century as the
atom was the paradox for the 20th
century so know they out there somehow
nature found a way around and what I
find extremely exciting for theoretical
physics and mathematics actually I feel
it's like a jigsaw puzzle we started on
the very edge the easy parts perhaps the
corners and now we're going into the
middle part where you actually see ideas
for many many fields coming together so
when you study gravity or quantum
physics or quantum information or very
pure math perhaps even number theory
somehow it all comes together so if
you're a young person right now you can
kind of have this great pleasure of
moving in all these worlds and still
thinking about the same problem so I
think that's actually extremely exciting
and I think that actually makes I think
you know this the I think like in
science you can say every year is the
most
sited your effort I think you're having
rights for every year so I took you sort
of down you know a little bit at first
but it ended with on a positive note I
want to take some questions now from the
audience I think you were first on this
side to me there are two outstanding
mysteries in quantum mechanics that you
haven't touched on tonight so I'd like
to get your opinion the one I'm not
really asking your opinion on is what
does quantum mechanics really tell us
about the nature of the universe
I fear that Einstein was wrong and God
does third ice but that's not my
question
the another outstanding problem is the
problem of measurement that you all know
about and John Bell probably close to
his death wrote an essay called on
measurement in which he challenged
quantum physicists to incorporate
measurement into quantum theory and I'd
like your comments by any of you on how
how much success how how things are
going on that course so yeah I've
written a lot about interpretive issues
with quantum mechanics basically the
question is what what does it mean what
is reality if if things are so
probabilistic on the quantum scale
nothing's real until you measure it you
know it brings up all these questions I
tend to think that that we just that in
the next revolution in physics when we
have a better deeper understanding that
it will be clear that our current
thoughts on this issue are naive and
that we will no longer be it
we won't it won't be that we turned it
turned out that a single interpretation
was right and the other ones weren't
it'll be just unimaginably different
thank you I think we should probably
also allow others to attend but and I
just want to say real quick that was a
great question and please do make sure
your questions are questions and
in brief so that we can get a few more
questions in today so let's start on the
side this is not exactly a specific
question but if you could comment on the
statement is it meaningful and what does
it mean for an axiom to be true that's
somewhat of mathematics yeah its
mathematical and philosophical but I
think you guys could have some good
answers or comments thanks for that deep
question
[Laughter]
panelists seem to be true I don't know
based in physics right like we we start
with axioms in math that seem true based
on our understanding it it's this
relates directly to this point of math
being discovered or invented so we think
often you know if it's natural
mathematical structures they are
discovered so somebody finds like
symmetry groups no okay that's a natural
thing but you can have very contrived
actions and then you have a creative
world well clearly you can discover
things in that world but at whole world
seem to be kind of made-up right so the
question is what are in some sense the
natural I mean that's how I reads what
are the natural actions and here you
might think that no perhaps indeed our
science physics reality experiences are
guiding us because we do not want to
have them completely now you can have
very sterile or very contrived
mathematical worlds that feel made-up
there's even the things that can sort of
undermine your attempts to to find out
you know sort of the fundamental axioms
in my inbox the quantum magazine has a
soft little sibling called Nautilus and
recently there was an article in
Nautilus about quantum quantum
entanglement and conscious
Penrose apparently has been dabbling in
this and looking at micro elements of
the brain specifically I believe it was
something like microtubules so I was
wondering whether that's a question that
you all have encountered it sounded like
a fair amount of the world dismisses it
out of hand and then there are a couple
of people who think that he well maybe
there is something there so I was
curious to hear whether anyone had any
thoughts on this and then in particular
relation to another I think growing
tradition of thought around a much more
decentralized architecture of the human
neural system so it's not just the brain
because in this case you had quantum
entanglement with elementary or micro
elements of the brain but if you have a
larger system that includes gotten the
toes and so on and so forth so any
thoughts I'll jump in at least sort of
briefly on a couple of those obviously
one one dismisses Roger Penrose casually
at one's peril that that said I think
you're right in saying that I think that
the view of most neuroscientists is that
an idea of trying to pin notions of
consciousness and where that comes down
to some sort of quantum effects
associated specifically with
microtubules seems questionable for a
variety of different reasons that I am
certainly not capable of being able to
say the moment but I know that is the
general state of it I think as with all
these sorts of issues the right
experiments coming along could easily
change pinions about that because it's
not as though we're have all sorts other
great ideas right now about where
consciousness is coming from but I don't
think that's a very favoured explanation
right now I think that there I think
your other comment about the sort of the
decentralization of a lot of functions
that we've tended to associate with the
brain itself I think that is a very
active area of research although I think
my own reading of the literature on that
is that most of that has less to do with
the notion with actual quantum effects
and more of a growing sense that in fact
that a lot of things that we thought
that had to be just purely localized
inside the brain can in fact be
distributed more outside to other parts
of the nervous system because that
information can be communicated and
shared in other ways that's a sort of
quick gloss on that anyway thank you
John and because we started a little bit
late we're gonna I'll take two more
questions and then afterwards we're
gonna have a little bit of reception
there'll be some refreshments outside
we'll do a book signing for those of you
who have books and so you'll have an
opportunity to talk with panelists
individually and ask your questions
there so we'll take just two more
questions
humankind is needed to find beauty in
reality and we see this in mathematics
in physics and any geometrical
explanation interpretation of nature
leads to certain buting just think of
symmetry Fibonacci series etc etc there
is a long tradition
can you speak other aesthetics or
cosmology is there such a thing well I
often remark that no beauty is becoming
something very contained contentious in
the in arts but in some sense it's now
migrating to science the ultimate refuge
of beauty and and if I think you know
somehow our definition of so it's right
remarkable that these equations and
objects and that we have a universal
sense of beauty you know you
mathematicians from all different
backgrounds agree this is a beautiful
equation I don't think there's a real
good definition of it but has something
to do I would almost say of the power
per symbol of the equation so the fact
that you with a very brief set of
concepts can explain a lot and so I
would say if you look at the great
beauty I see in physics now and I've
written about is in one column in the
physics collection you find it at the
two
all physically add a very small to very
large where things start to simplify
basically because you either zoom in so
closely that you don't see any of the
messy details or you zoom out so largely
you only see the big picture and in
these two area I think the equations say
Einstein's equations or the equations of
the standard model are incredibly
beautiful because they are so powerful
so just the fact that with a very simple
set of equations for describing fourteen
billion years of evolution again the
surprise again again has been that
people think of all kind of bells and
whistles to add to it and the nature
proves them wrong
so there is something I find it very
comforting that you know there is we I
think we're trying to read the character
of nature and the thing what she likes
and I think it's the kind of equations
that we like to on the subject of
mathematical beauty I mean for anybody
who hasn't heard of this a number of
years ago the mathematician Michael
attea and and some neuroscientists did a
paper where they looked at such like as
my eyes was something of mathematician
or people's brains mathematicians brains
as they were looking at different
equations to see which patterns matched
the patterns of other people looking at
beautiful art and sort of the aesthetics
of that and they found that the the one
equation that most mathematicians found
to be the most beautiful was Oilers
equation where there's identity e to the
I PI plus one equals zero and it does
embody all the things that Robert was
just talking about one last question
I saw Roberts comments on quantum
mechanics being a mathematical teacher
made me think about you know the recent
computing systems involving the
blockchain and decentralized computing
how that's pushed sort of the frontiers
of cryptography and a lot of other stuff
and so I wonder first of all when do you
think the first hobby quantum computer
will be available what questions and
and topics you know do you think you
know could be addressed in terms of
quantum mechanics and mathematics that
this potential computer would sort of
spur they always say twenty years twenty
years would be another 20 years of
course tell you exactly when it will be
available but not where I don't know we
can give you a better answer than that
thank you everyone and again we will
have some refreshments outside a little
bit of a reception and if you have books
you'd like us to sign the panelists
except for Robby I think you have to
leave right unfortunately won't have
Robert but we thank you for being here
and for your amazing insights that you
shared with us and all the panelists
today
[Music]